[Musique]
raconte moi quand les filles jenna dit
tu fais ce que c'est un apiculteur
moi j'ai été apiculteurs qui touche
unique
en quoi quelques fleurs à soigner et je
suis à toi
ou la vaillante petite bête qui parle tu
viens me voir père aimait bien tout
doucement
l'office pas de brûler leurs gardes et y
voir une à bell
elle est en train de butiner il mange la
feuille
non elle ramasse le pôle m tiens c'est
l'essence titi et puis elle ira faire ou
du miel
là bas aussi ya une autre année il doit
y avoir un effet un tel qu pas un effet
fait toute la famille quoi toutes les
batailles ensemble elles s'appliquent
quelque part c'est ça paye bien sûr
elles font leur miel dans une ruche puis
s'il n'y a pas tout à fait vrai eh bien
nous allons leur en faire une tu sais en
faire des choses qui petits monstres kg
ma nuit la meilleure c'est titus tenue
faire et donner quelques coups de bâton
ça me distraire à rouillac 1 mais titus
n'a rien fait de mal justement inhalé
fait ni bien ni mal ans et elle est
capable va me le chercher mons car tout
même quand y'a qu'à tout même
la jolie petite maison d'apple voilà
vous termine lotois ya les poètes ils
viendront faire le miel ici c'est
charmant c'est une ruche mais sport et
fais-moi l'apiculteur est contré le miel
est pour le moment et j'ai bien peur que
tu ne récolte que quelques coups de
bateaux car le gros y'a qu'à veux te
voir à longueau legrand ya pas c'est pas
du miel écoute mosca les semoirs
accompagné bérénice à sa potiche après
j'irai voir le grand yaka d'accord titus
je vais le faire patienter et titus aux
oies titus je vais le voir ici
il viendra dans un instant il travaille
il soigne les fleurs je vais voir à ce
travail ça m'amuse de voir travailler
titus titus titus qui te casser c'est
une petite maison on me l'avait caché
aux mocassins tout alla au mam un homme
à mort du chauffeur
il faut s'approcher doucement pour ne
pas effrayer les abeilles sinon épique
[Musique]
mais mes mains tenue d'apiculteur
si bérénice me voyait elle me prendrait
pour le lion au masque de fer par ici le
bon miel tout vrai titus titus quelle
affaire
oh c'est un cauchemar c'est bien toi tu
ce n'est ni mon score tu veux goûter au
miel de mes abeilles bon pas de miel
pendant le service
titus il faut que tu ailles chez le gros
jacquat ans c'est vrai vous l'avez
oublié comme en haïti
tu verras tu verras au mama mama du
pouvoir et à face aux catastrophes a dit
fait piquer par mais ça paye oh yes i do
us
j'ai soigné mes petites mains des
figures est tout gonflé voilà grand ya
pas voilà un peu de douceur
écoutez ce miel et vous vous oublierez
toutes nos souffrances
c'est beau c'est doux ça me fait du bien
encore un peu de miel titus tu es une
bonne petite lionne et tu n'auras pas de
coups de marteau de deux mois encore
d'une elles sont ventilés abeilles
le mien c'est meilleur que les coups de
bâton et un prêt après fait notre
histoire
[Musique]